- Un vaste chantier, sur tout
un étage d'immeuble.
Encore quelques couches de
et Kimberlee Clarke
pourra terminer l'aménagement.
- Donc ici ça va être une salle
d'exposition pour une oeuvre
d'art multimédia
ou une installation.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On est au bord de l'autoroute
métropolitaine, dans le quartier
Saint-Michel. C'est là que les
Ateliers 3333, de Marc Séguin,
sont en train de voir le jour.
KIMBERBLEE CLARKE
coordonnatrice des Ateliers 3333
- Parce qu'on n'aurait pas pu
le faire dans les quartiers qui
sont le Plateau Mont Royal ou
le Mile End, tous ces quartiers-
là qui ont historiquement été
très créatifs, mais on pouvait
pas se le permettre.
- À terme, ils veulent
accueillir près d'une centaine
de créateurs dans tout
l'immeuble.
Les cas d'artistes qui perdent
leur locaux se sont multipliés
avec la flambée de l'immobilier.
Il y a eu le cas du
305 Bellechasse, par exemple,
ou de l'édifice Cadbury.
Aujourd'hui, c'est une jeune
coopérative qui s'apprête à
quitter ce bâtiment de la rue
Masson, mais parce qu'elle va
devenir propriétaire, juste à
côté.
MADLY FUSS, designeure ébéniste
présidente de la coop MADAAM
- La perle rare, mais vraiment!
On a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
chance, c'est un projet qui va
très, très vite en fait,
comparativement à ce qu'on nous
avait dit au départ.
- Peu de temps après que Madly,
l'artiste-ébéniste eût fondé
sa coopérative, Québec et
Montréal ont mis la main à
la poche.
NATHALIE ROY, ministre Culture
- Je vous annonce que
le gouvernement du Québec
investit 25 millions de dollars.
- Et Montréal a ajouté
5 millions tout en précisant :
VALÉRIE PLANTE
mairesse de Montréal
- Le programme d'aujourd'hui
n'est pas, par exemple, pour
acheter un bâtiment.
- Et pourtant, huit mois plus
tard, Valérie Plante visite
la coopérative d'artistes.
- Fait qu'est-ce que ça a permis
le projet pilote?
- Ça a tout permis.
(rires)
- Et notamment près d'un demi-
million de dollars pour parvenir
à ceci :
- Donc c'est ça, on a prévu
un deux mois de plus pour
faire l'acquisition.
- Une offre d'achat sur
un bâtiment où 90 % de
la facture des rénovations sera
couverte par la subvention.
Une aide pour pallier les effets
de l'embourgeoisement.
- Demandez à un propriétaire
privé : tu peux pas augmenter
tes loyers. Je n'ai pas cette
possibilité-là. Par contre,
comme Ville, j'ai la possibilité
de soutenir, puis c'est pas
juste donner de l'argent pour
le loyer, c'est vraiment de leur
donner de l'accompagnement pour
qu'elles s'organisent, et faire
une coop et acheter un building.
- Ou financer à hauteur
de 5 millions la transformation
du 3333 Crémazie.
- c'est sûr qu'on va aider
probablement 200, 300 artistes,
peut-être.
- C'est lui, la ressource
inespérée qui a guidé la coop
à travers les méandres
administratifs.
CHARLES GRENIER, chargé dévelop.
Atelier habitation Montréal
- Ce qui est bien avec ce genre
de projets là, c'est que la coop
MADAM va avoir un contrôle au
niveau des augmentations de
loyer. Ils auront pas à attendre
après un propriétaire de :
on fait un bail d'un an, est-ce
que je vais être renouvelé,
c'est quoi l'augmentation que
je vais subir?
- Une crainte omniprésente
dans le milieu.
- Ici on est dans les Ateliers
Casgrain, on est un groupe d'à
peu près 15 artistes maintenant,
puis, comme vous voyez, il y a
les murs qu'on a construits
phase 1.
- Ils ont la garantie de rester
locataires 25 ans d'un
propriétaire qui bénéficie
d'un incitatif.
CATHERINE BODMER, dir. Regroup.
centres d'artistes autogérés Qc
- Pour que ça soit avantageux,
on a besoin de la ville, on a
besoin des arrondissements qui
permettent aux propriétaires
d'avoir droit à des dérogations
par exemple.
- Comme celle de pouvoir louer
une plus grande surface sans
contrainte réglementaire.
Quant à la hausse continue de
la valeur foncière.
ÉRIKA ALNEUS, responsable
culture comité exécutif Montréal
- Au niveau des taxes on
rembourse jusqu'à 100 %,
à concurrence de 130 000,
sur deux exercices financiers,
les taxes foncières. Donc en
plus de soutenir l'acquisition
et la rénovation, on soutient
les premières années où on
est conscients que le fait de
rénover ou d'acquérir augmente
la taxe.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est la faiblesse
du programme selon
Catherine Bodmer.
- Malheureusement, après ces
deux ans, on est très inquiets
en fait de voir, après avoir
tout aménagé ces espaces-là,
les taxes vont augmenter,
comment ça va jouer sur
les loyers au final.
Donc c'est ça un peu le paradoxe
qui existe où la Ville veut
soutenir la pérennisation
des ateliers puis en même temps
dépend complètement des taxes.
- Les artistes montréalais
doivent, en tout cas, faire
preuve de créativité pour
continuer. Que ce soit en
s'excentrant dans le quartier
Chabanel pour certains, au bord
de l'autoroute pour d'autres,
ou en réussissant à rester au
coeur de la ville.
♪ ♪ ♪